slicing through the waves of the cote
d'azur this 40-foot powerboat is a bit
different than most luxury yachts while
it's minimal design might not appeal to
everyone 14 knots it's fast and its
makers say they're targeting fires with
more than one vessel already this market
is growing for people who have a flat or
a bigger boat and won't have only about
a useful boat - going out to have a
party with the family or friends fuel
boat says simplicity is key for instance
it has an easy-to-use joystick to steer
the boat meaning any untrained sailor
can pick it up and without deriving the
design behind the boat the company says
it hasn't had to do a great deal to
improve sales in the last few years
while the financial crisis hurt many
industries fueled says there's
flourished today we raise our phaser and
the middle range of price of the boats
more cries and more big boats and flour
expensive boats they want the perfect
boat and a perfect service and all
together post-crash fuel change tack
when looking for buyers while it's sold
fewer smaller boats interest in its
bigger boats with all in extras like
servicing packages grew as a result
they're building bigger in someone so we
will have the new the biggest both of
the range is the fuel the 48 with the
record for the world's biggest yacht
being broken nearly every year there's
only one way these boat builders are
likely to go Tom Gibson Bloomberg